[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be diving into once again
an analysis comparing book with film
specifically we're going to be taking a
look at the deaths of 10 Harry Potter
characters and how these deaths were
portrayed differently on the Silver
Screen we'll also be diving into the
implications for portraying these deaths
differently when adapting a beloved book
series to the big screen filmmakers face
the daunting task of translating the
rich intricate world of the source
material into a visual medium nariposa
is no exception with its complex
characters intricate plot lines and
Magical elements capturing the essence
of the books while keeping the films
engaging and accessible for a wide
audience is a challenge the portrayals
of characters deaths which often carry
deep emotional weight and thematic
significance are not excluded from these
challenges today we'll explore notable
differences between the deaths of
characters in the Harry Potter books and
their film adaptations discussing the
impact of these changes on the story and
the characters involved Professor
Quirrell in the film Professor coronis
Quill's entire body combusts after Harry
lays his hands on him creating a
visually stunning scene as he
disintegrates into ashes in the book
however geral's body is able to
withstand Harry's touch leaving him
weakened but still very much alive he
later dies off screen when Voldemort
leaves his body Dumbledore explains to
Harry he left quarrel to die he shows
just as little Mercy to his followers as
his enemies Frank Bryce in the film
muggle Frank Bryce's death is made to
appear more menacing by the presence of
Voldemort Peter Pettigrew and Barty
crunch Jr in this scene Frank appears
frail lost and disoriented heightening
the sense of vulnerability and fear by
contrast the book showcases a much more
courageous version of Frank Bryce in the
book he overhears a conversation between
Lord Voldemort and his acolytes in the
riddle house following his eavesdropping
Frank bravely confronts Voldemort and
Peter Pettigrew after hearing their
plans Voldemort taunts Frank and upon
realizing that he has no useful
information kills him using the killing
curse Frank's death marks the beginning
of the story and foreshadows the dark
events that unfold in the book Barty
Grant senior in the film bodycraft
senior's corpse is discovered by Harry
Ron and Hermione in the Forbidden Forest
serving as a shocking Revelation that
sets the stage for the uncovering of
Barty Crouch Jr's true identity we do
find out that Crouch senior dies but
unfortunately the film entirely omits
the details of Barty Crouch senior's
death in the book however body Crouch
senior's death is much more Sinister and
dark as we find out that he was murdered
by his own son Barty Crouch Jr with the
killing curse after killing his father
bharti Jr transfigures his father's body
into a bone and buries it in the
Hogwarts grounds this adds a twisted
aspect to the father-son relationship
highlighting Barty Crouch Jr.'s cold and
ruthless nature Crouch Jr was awful but
I will say that Crouch senior was no
saint either
Sirius Black in the film Sirius is
killed when Bellatrix Lestrange finds
the killing curse at him while standing
in front of the veil after he struck
with the curse we see Sirius fall
backward into the veil but the whole
ordeal is a little confusing because he
still seems to be somewhat conscious
after being struck with Avada Kedavra
the killing curse instantly kills people
so the way that his death is portrayed
doesn't quite make sense in the book
however he is hit by a standard curse
that strikes his heart causing his body
to fall to the veil in the death chamber
the veil in the death chamber acts as
the physical manifestation of the
barrier between the land of the living
and the dead and because Sirius crossed
over this barrier he died madai moody in
the film Madame Moody's death is given
almost no attention after arriving at
the burrow following the Battle of the
seven Potters Bill Weasley briefly
mentions that Mad Eye didn't make it in
the book however there's a little bit
more to it as it's revealed that
Voldemort killed him after the mandungus
Fletcher abandoned him and fled the
scene following Moody's death Harry Ron
and Hermione discuss Moody's possible
fate Clinging On to a small possibility
that he may have made it out alive but
Bill saw him hit by the killing curse at
Harry yeah but Bill was under attack too
said Ron how can he be sure what he saw
even if the kalinkas missed madai still
fell about a thousand feet said Hermione
now weighing Quidditch teams of Britain
and Ireland in her hand he could have
used the shield charm flow said his one
was blasted out of his hand said Harry
the way that Moody was discarded in the
films did not do any kind of Justice to
his character Fred Weasley in the
Deathly Hallows Fred Weasley's death is
briefly highlighted during the Battle of
Hogwarts the film doesn't show the exact
circumstances of Fred's death but it
does show Harry Ron and Hermione
discovering Fred's lifeless body a
painful reminder of what was at stake
that effectively conveys the grief and
pain felt by his family and friends in
the book however he dies with his
brother Percy by his side and a smile on
his face after a huge explosion this
detail in the book adds a Bittersweet
element to Fred's death as he dies
laughing and reconnecting with his
estranged brother just before the
explosion Fred says to Percy you're
actually joking purse I don't think I've
heard you joke since you were was ever a
Snape in the film Voldemort slashes
Snape's throat and instructs nagini to
finish him off making his death much
more gruesome and violent than the book
equivalent as Voldemort orders nagini to
kill Snape he coldly States you've been
a good and faithful servant Severus but
only I can live forever the book version
of the scene is similar with the notable
omission of any form of throat slashing
in the book Voldemort orders nagini to
attack Snape which leads to him pleading
profusely however there is no throat
slashing involved as he lies dying Snape
gives Harry his memories to reveal the
truth about his past and his allegiance
to Dumbledore this change in the film
heightens The brutality of Voldemort's
actions and the suffering Snape endures
before dying Bellatrix Lestrange in the
film Molly Weasley performs a spell that
causes Bellatrix to swell up and explode
providing a visually striking and
satisfying end to her character this
happens after Molly Weasley steps in to
protect Ginny from The Vicious dark
wedge it's unclear what spell she
actually used but if you're curious then
go and check out my video on the topic
once you're finished here in the book
Bellatrix is killed by a curse that hits
her in the heart similar to Siri's
Black's death after being struck
Bellatrix simply topples over rather
than being blown to Pieces bellatrix's
gloating smile froze her eyes seem to
bulge for the tiny space of time she
knew what had happened and then she
toppled and the watching crowd roared
and Voldemort screamed Voldemort in the
film Voldemort turns to dust after his
killing curse rebounds back at him
symbolizing the end of his dark Reign
and the disintegration of his evil power
because he disintegrates vol Voldemort's
body is nowhere to be found in the book
however Voldemort's body remains intact
later being moved to a separate location
for burial this difference in the book
highlights the idea that despite his
quest for immortality Voldemort
ultimately dies a mortal death leaving
behind a physical body like any other
person when Voldemort dies nothing
special happens he's reduced to a corpse
just like anyone else Voldemort always
saw death dying as pure weakness a fate
reserved for the unimportant and
Powerless so I really appreciate his
death in the books being so commonplace
to me his film death felt a little too
over the top Peter Pettigrew in the film
pettigrew's death is barely shown
leaving his fate entirely uncertain in
the book however pettigrew's silverhand
given to him by Voldemort turns on him
and strangles him to death when he
hesitates to stop Harry and Ron from
escaping this important scene from the
book highlights the theme of paying for
one's past voices and the consequences
of aligning with evil forces if you want
a full analysis on the differences
between pettigrew's death in the books
versus films then check out my video on
it lavender Brown in the Harry Potter
films it's quite clear that lavender
Brown does in fact die she falls off of
a balcony and then gets Savaged by
Infamous werewolf fenrik greybach
actress Jessie cave who portrays
lavender even confirmed this in an
interview what was the last scene you
filmed on the very last film mine was my
death scene which is quite fitting
really the same can't be said for the
books however which leave lavender's
fate a little more uncertain two bodies
fell from the balcony overhead as they
reached the ground a gray blur that
Harry took for an animal sped
four-legged across the hall to sink its
teeth into one of the Fallen no shrieked
Hermione and with a deafening Blast from
her wand fenrik Grayback was thrown
backward from the feebly staring body of
lavender Brown in the book Hermione
appears to save lavender from greybank
leaving her feebly stirring after the
attack though it's likely that lavender
didn't make it we don't have absolute
confirmation the changes to lavender's
fate in the film highlight the brutality
and horror of the battle emphasizing the
indiscriminate nature of the violence
and the tragedy of losing young lives
and calling creepy in the film Colin's
death is not shown or mentioned which
helped alleviate the emotional weight of
losing such a familiar and innocent
character the book however showcased
this a lot differently in the book Colin
creepy's death is a poignant moment that
highlights the devastating impact of the
war on the students at Hogwarts he dies
during the Battle of Hogwarts and Harry
discovers his body in the Great Hall
among the Fallen Colin's death is
particularly tragic because he was
underage and had been ordered to leave
the castle before the battle but he
sneaked back into fight Hedwig in the
film hedwig's death is shown after she's
released from our cage and flies into
the path of a killing curse appearing to
sacrifice herself to protect Harry this
change from the books adds an element of
heroism to hedwig's death and emphasizes
her loyalty to Harry in the book however
hedwig's death occurs when she is hit by
a straight killing curse while still in
her cage symbolizing the loss of
innocence and the end of Harry's
childhood while the film versions
incorporation of heroism was a nice
touch it didn't feel quite as sudden as
the books Rufus grimga I don't think the
film's all the books do much Justice to
the death of Minister for magic Rufus
grimga the films briefly mention his
death while Harry and Co are attending
Bill Weasley and Fleur de la core's
wedding it's here that an announcement
is made that scrimga had been killed and
that the ministry of magic had fallen to
Voldemort and while the fate of scrim
girl in the films felt incomplete the
books don't really cover it much better
only including a few additional details
in the books Remus Lupine reveals that
scrimga was tortured by Voldemort in an
effort to get him to reveal the
whereabouts of Harry Potter after
refusing to divulge any information it's
revealed that scrim girl was killed by
Voldemort the omission of skrimke's
death from the films stunt scrimke's
character development as it fails to
depict The Bravery that he displayed in
the face of certain death Vincent Crabb
Gregory Goyle in the book Vincent Crabb
dies during the Battle of Hogwarts when
he accidentally sets off the powerful
fiend fire spell in the room of
requirements unable to control the
magical fire grab is consumed by the
Flames which also destroys one of
Voldemort's horcruxes in the film
adaptation of the Deathly Hallows
however crab's role is replaced by
Gregory Goyle who suffers the same faint
this change was made due to the
real-life unavailability of the actor
who portrayed crab and that's it for
this video did you know about these
differences which versions do you prefer
leave a comment down below until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live